[Music]
[Applause]
he's uh the new raiders head coach josh
mcdaniels of course many years as the
patriots offensive coordinator and
won six super bowls with that team nice
hoodie you got there with your raiders
gear what'd you do with all your patriot
gear
we haven't done anything with it yet uh
i i haven't i haven't i haven't been
back home since i came out uh thursday
and
i'm sure we'll find find good use for it
uh you in a hotel out there in vegas
yeah yes i am but not on the strip
not on the stream
off the strip a little bit in a little
quieter place what was the conversation
like with coach belichick when you told
him you were leaving
yeah that was uh you know
that was a very important uh
conversation for me and bill and i i
think have a deep respect for one
another um i'm certainly grateful for
all the time that i've spent there and
everything that he's done for me and my
family
not easy conversations to have
you know i knew it would take a special
place for me to leave where i was at um
and i and i communicated that with bill
with mr kraft
and again those were those were
emotional conversations and rightfully
so we spent a lot of time together
they've done so much for me in my career
and i'm super grateful for the time that
i spent there can you
answer this question uh honestly did the
patriots try to trade for derek carr
last season
i i know nothing about any of that
that's the right answer but it just
shows how much you love derek carr
yeah yeah derek look i i'm excited about
this um derek and i had a chance to talk
the other day had a great conversation
i've competed against him a number of
times in his career he's done a lot of
great things in this league took this
team to the playoffs uh you know it was
super competitive all year long and you
know it's and now it's exciting to join
forces here and and see what we can do
to put the best group around him
i love the nucleus there i mean you got
your quarterback you got your running
back you got your tight end um
i i love crosby you know
yeah
do you how close do you feel you're in a
very very competitive division here but
yeah no question um yeah no look we have
we have good players and uh you know in
the national football league every year
there's change every year there's a
roster construction that needs to take
place and
this will be no different for us um i'm
excited to partner with dave zigler and
in that process and try to
improve this football team in every way
that we can but there's no doubt that
they had a they had a successful season
uh it didn't finish the way uh that that
anybody you know wants to finish you
know it happens for one of us out of 32
but um you know getting to the
postseason you know four guys in the pro
bowl here coming up this week there's
definitely some talented players on this
team that we're going to get to know
and we're looking forward to that
process
best day you ever had as a member of the
patriots was what
oh boy um
my favorite uh my favorite memory was
probably the 14 super bowl against
seattle um
you know and we were fortunate
so blessed to have so many great
memories there um i think if if there
was one particular day that i
might have enjoyed more than the rest um
it was it was the first time that we had
actually won a super bowl uh where i had
where i had children and uh
you know my two oldest kids were at the
game and got to share in that
celebration on the field afterwards with
my wife uh my father so um you know that
was it was it was a 10-year gap
in in terms of us being able to
to win one of those and and to realize
that again and and live through that
with your family and your children it
was pretty special
yesterday was the anniversary of the
malcolm butler interception
i didn't know that i didn't even know
that that's pretty cool i was
at the i was at the goal post because
i'm gonna i'm handing out the trophy uh
right after the game
and i'm i'm thinking as russ goes back
because i'm watching marshawn lynch
because i'm just saying i'm gonna watch
i had my phone out i'm gonna watch
marshawn lynch go right in for a
touchdown here and then all of a sudden
he didn't get it russ goes back and i go
oh bleep and then
i didn't know malcolm had the
interception dude none of us did i
understood i could i couldn't tell what
happened i knew there was a big cheer
and from where we were sitting you know
we were over there on the bench at the
50-yard line and it was kind of like you
know it's down here to the left and
you're not sure
nobody had any idea what happened it was
just a big roar and then we were
grateful that malcolm made that
incredible play he brought it up two
days after the super bowl when we had
him on and he said bill walked him
through that play
yeah wednesday of super bowl week yep
yep it happened multiple times actually
um i remember you know we practiced
those types of situations many times and
i think there was a lot of guys because
seattle had used that concept with
multiple personnel groupings and
formations and so on so there was a lot
of our defensive players that i think
were prepped and ready for the type of
play that was um and we're just
fortunate that malcolm you know made
such a great play on the ball what would
you have called in that situation
i don't know that's a great question you
know because hindsight's always 20 20 um
you know and and i think you what you
would call there is the play you had the
most confidence in when i was in that
similar situation
um in the atlanta super bowl a couple
years later um we used our two point
plays and so you know you you practice
those for those types of situations uh
you don't always have to use a two-point
play on you know on a two-point play you
can use it at the one or two-yard line
in a critical situation and so that's
what we had used in 16
in a similar scenario when we found
ourselves in that spot
did you ever take it personally when tom
changed your play
no
never no he had
well i might i might have thought mine
was better at times but you know we we
we
we knew that he understood and had a
tremendous grasp on everything he did
and so whenever that happened uh he
always had a good reason for doing so if
i told you a month ago that brady was
going to be retired what would you have
said
um i would have been surprised you know
um
obviously he had such an a tremendous
season this year i mean statistically
and otherwise and took his team to the
postseason and had a chance to make
another run
he's such a competitive guy and i've
always felt like you know if tom was
playing at a high level which obviously
he was this year that he would probably
keep playing i think we all kind of you
know all of us that have been around him
and gotten to know him know him so well
probably assumed he would play until he
just couldn't do it anymore um and so
when he i talked to him the other night
and uh you know heard the news it was it
was kind of shocking you know and um
such a such an important and
uh you know integral part to the
league's history and especially the last
22 23 years here i mean he's he's kind
of been a mainstay in all those
important conversations about who's
going to win the super bowl and what
teams are you know really in it and all
that and um you know we'll miss him i'm
sure we will as a league i'll miss him
in terms of seeing him play as a former
coach of his uh and and look forward to
his next chapter i'm sure it's going to
be successful whatever he chooses to do
you were 32 i think when you got the
broncos job i think you're now 45.
what's the difference between josh
mcdaniels at 32 as a head coach and josh
mcdaniels at 45.
yeah i i didn't think i don't think i
had much wisdom then you know i knew a
little football um i've been around you
know a good organization for eight years
and had learned some things about you
know what my job entailed there and
tried to do it to the best of my ability
but really learned a lot about you know
the the important parts to each area of
the organization how much people
need your support need your impact on a
daily basis and how much they value that
and their contribution and understanding
how they fit into the bigger picture and
i think i have a much different
perspective on things now um i have four
kids i've been a parent for a
a lot longer now than i was then and i
think i've just grown in so many ways
from the from that failure and and tried
to implement that in the day-to-day
process that i've used as a coach you
know in the last 10 to 12 years so i'm
thankful for the opportunity to try it
again
all right help me understand this
raiders owner mark davis said that you
told him
that tom brady fumbled on the tuck rule
play
i had to play the other side of the
fence when i came here i saw the
facility and i said the first thing i'm
going to say to break the ice is that it
was a fumble and so
i i felt like i ingratiated myself to
him pretty well right off the bat if you
were still in new england and you saw
mark davis
it probably wouldn't have been a fumble
yeah probably probably a part of raider
nation now so it was a fumble well
congrats on this and we appreciate your
time josh thank you
thanks a lot dan appreciate it that's
josh mcdaniels he is the new head coach
of your las vegas raiders